since the West was settled farmers have
been turning rangeland into fields to
produce food for a growing population
many used a method called dryland
farming or agriculture without
irrigation dryland farming is an
agricultural practice that involves the
use of drought tolerant crops and
banking soil moisture it is common in
areas that have a wet season usually in
the winter or early spring in Wyoming
for dryland farming to be successful the
area must receive at least 15 inches of
precipitation annually and most of this
must come in the late winter or early
spring as heavy wet snow
moisture from the wet period is stored
in the soil the crops use that moisture
to germinate and grow traditional
dryland farming in Wyoming
uses a technique known as strip farming
one strip of land is planted and another
strip of land is left fallow fallow is a
period of no tillage where stubble from
the last year's crop is left to protect
the soil from erosion each year the
planted and fallow strips are rotated a
more modern form of dryland farming
requires no tillage each year the new
crop is planted into the stubble of the
fallowed strip and tillage does not
occur from the University of Wyoming
extension I'm Ashley girls exploring the
nature of Wyoming
you
[Music]